depuis le 1er confinement en mars 2020
locaux vides 19 a eu des impacts dans de
nombreux domaines c'est notamment le cas
pour les relations amoureuses pour en
parler avec nous ce soir justin brasier
journalistes de la rédaction
bonsoir mon sens alors c'est plus
compliqué de faire des rencontres avec
la crise sanitaire j'imagine il ya en
tout cas moins de possibilités de se
rencontrer de façon naturelle pour
plusieurs raisons déjà la réduction du
nombre de contacts pour éviter la
propagation et par peur aussi d'être
contaminés il est aussi compliqué de se
voir le soir avec le couvre-feu à moins
de revenir tôt ou d'habiter ensemble
mais bon ce n'est pas forcément le cas
en début de relation et puis comment se
découvrir dans la vraie vie quand les
établissements culturels ou encore les
restaurants et bars et activités ne sont
plus accessibles les endroits où on
pouvait faire des rencontres comme les
facs lycée tous là bas comme sandy
essentielle pour la plupart fait
compliqué mais moins tentés à parler aux
gens on est vraiment chacun dans leur
bulle et c'est un peu frustrant quand on
a du mal à croiser des personnes on a du
mal à aller vers les personnes parce que
déjà il ya la distance dans la
dispensation en fait donc du coup on a
de la retenue faute de pouvoir se
rencontrer dans un bar où aller au
restaurant rencontrer des gens un peu
dans des milieux où il ya du monde et de
l'ambiance
j'ai recours à des sites internet je
trouve pas ça vraiment original et ce
que j'aimerais masse et de rencontres en
vrai peut-être que parler sur internet
ça fait voir en vrai et que du coup ça
peut aider des sites de rencontres alors
justin est ce que les sites de
rencontres ont eux aussi été impactés
alors on pourrait se dire que c'est un
peu la seule manière de se rencontrer
aujourd'hui alors match et c'est bien
mais quand vient l'heure de la rencontre
est bien le même fin les mêmes problèmes
se posent ça s'est ressenti au niveau
des chiffres dont qu'on a pierre
tabuteau qui est yves binois plus
précisément deux maisons laffitte et il
a créé son site de statistiques qui
s'appelle stats rencontres.fr dans
lequel y compare il compare et analyse
les données de sites de rencontres en
france et donc selon une étude publiée
en janvier 2021 les sites de rencontres
généralistes auraient connu une large
baisse au 1er confinement avec moins 60
% quand même de fréquentation par
rapport à l'année
2019 il a eu ensuite un rebond à l'été
2020 ou là par contre la tendance est
inversée puisque la fréquentation a
connu une croissance de 20% quand même
par rapport à 2019 et ensuite face à la
deuxième vague est donc le deuxième
confinement d'africains la fréquentation
des sites de rencontres à elle de
nouveau baisser cette fois ci plus
légèrement avec moins 40% par rapport à
2010 9 mai donc moins 20% par rapport au
rebond de l'été 2021 eh bien merci
justin pour toutes ces précisions
chiffrées qui plus est